are you ready for Destiny's last big
event it seems like a great way to look
back at everything you've done since the
game's launch in 2014 I'm Tony this is a
game spot news update and if you want to
be the first to know what Bungie creates
next be sure to subscribe age of
triumphs most important addition is a
new record book the biggest one the team
has ever created it's 13 pages are
filled with challenges based on story
events raids and special achievements if
you've been playing destiny for a long
time it'll be reflected here but even
veterans will have plenty of new
objectives to check off the other big
change is coming to raids with every
single one getting a new 390 light level
along with the game's new overall light
level maximum of four hundred age of
triumph will also have raids of the week
each one with special rewards and every
challenge mode turned on it all kicks
off on Tuesday March 28th on ps4 and
xbox one and more details will be
trickling out in the coming weeks age of
triumph is the last hurrah for destiny
since destiny 2 or whatever it ends up
being called is slated for release this
fall for more shooter news in the
meantime you can check out our review in
progress for Ghost Recon wildlands and
for all the gun-toting game news you're
already in the right place
[Music]
you